So now let's actually
look at translation,
something I had ignored before.
This is the way, the best way,
I can actually translate an image or
pixel points on an image.
Right?
Take any x and y value, and
actually have to give a translation,
tx and ty.
This simple addition would actually give
me newer x and ys, x prime, y prime.
Notice that this matrix representation
does not allow me to reconstruct this.
Right?
Because in this matrix representation,
shown by this, when I do a multi,
a matrix multiply becomes ax plus by for
x prime.
X prime would basically
become ax plus by.
And similarly,
y prime would become cx plus dy.
Notice almost impossible in this linear
combination formulation that we've
looked at that we can generate
an equation that matches this.
In essence, these terms are additive.
As opposed,
these are linear combinations.
So then, question to all of you,
how do we resolve this?
How do we come up with a way,
in this form of a matrix representation,
that will allow us to encode
things like translation?